[Music]
the winklevoss twins net worth 3 billion
each or 6 billion in total category
early investors and infrastructure
builders
2008 two twin brothers were awarded 65
million dollars in the settlement
against mark zuckerberg and facebook
a conflict that was later popularized by
the movie the social network
that 65 mil was split between the twins
and their partner what the movie didn't
get to include was that just nine years
after that settlement these scene twins
would go from in their eyes being
cheated by zuckerberg to joining the
ranks of zuckerberg as the world's first
bitcoin billionaires
2010 the twins completed their mbas at
oxford university and needed places to
invest their settlements so they went on
to form their own venture capital firm
winklevoss capital the problem was that
startup after startup were refusing to
take their money can you imagine a
problem like that
you have all this money that you're
trying to hand people who are begging
for money and no one will take it
it turns out that because they were
still in their lawsuit with facebook at
the time starters were afraid of
facebook going after them as retaliation
and the twins were shunned out of
silicon valley winklevoss capital was
dead before it even started
june 2012 two years later the twins were
on vacation on an island off the coast
of spain called ibiza when they were
first introduced to bitcoin by early
adopters
the idea that money was the ultimate
social network that bitcoin was free
from central banks and backed by math
appealed to them
so they went to new york and started
dumping their millions into bitcoin 11
million to be exact when bitcoin was at
just 120
a coin may 2013 one year later they
invested 1.5 million into an exchange
called bit instant
which allowed users to exchange dollars
for bitcoin in just a few minutes
at one point bit instant was reportedly
handling 30 of all bitcoin purchases
unfortunately the site was eventually
shut down in 2014 with the ceo arrested
for money laundering more than a million
dollars in bitcoin on the dark website
silk road
yet another public humiliation for the
twins and it wouldn't be the last time a
feature crypto billionaire had ties to
the silk road
2014 after that debacle the twins
realized that if they were going to
succeed in the wild west of cryptoland
they needed to bring some order to this
unregulated industry
so they founded gemini their own
cryptocurrency exchange if you're into
crypto you might have heard of gemini
before
they're a pretty respected exchange
today and in order to get to this point
instead of taking facebook's approach of
move fast and break things
they tried their best to stay on the
right side of the law this time with an
ask permission first not forgiveness
later ethos and by october 2015
gemini became the first bitcoin focused
financial institution to be designated
as a trusted bank by the new
york state department of financial
services this meant that they were
subject to the same regulatory
requirements as regular banks
november 26 2017 the winklevoss twins
become the first ever crypto
billionaires
today gemini is still tiny compared to
giants like coinbase and binance but
where gemini shines is in their trust
score
how trustworthy they are in terms of
trading and not getting hacked they have
their gemini dollar
a stable coin that's pecked in the us
dollar they're one of the few applying
to launch a crypto etf and doing a bunch
of other cool stuff too
in 2019 the twins stumbled upon a crypto
punk for the first time selling as an
nft
on the platform nifty gateway and one of
the twins tyler bought one for five
thousand dollars right there on the
spots
seven months later gemini bought nifty
gateway at only seven months old
perfect timing right before the recent
nft explosion and other than that
they're invested in at least 25 other
crypto related startups
which doesn't include their regular
winklevoss capital investments
if you've watched this channel you know
that one of the most common ways tycoons
make it to the top is by jumping on
trends
riding huge waves bernard arnell became
the third richest man in the world with
the fashion wave
marquez brownlee became the king of tech
reviews with the youtube wave and all
these billionaires with the crypto wave
that's just getting started
and the best place to start a company to
ride this crypto wave or any other type
of startup
america america has its problems but
it's still widely regarded as the best
place for startups
sure you can code a website from
anywhere but what you can do outside of
america is take advantage of this giant
mature startup infrastructure
nowhere else in the world do you have
access to so many venture capitalists
and angel investors to fund your idea
talent startup veterans and startup
accelerators to build your idea and
share their secrets with you the network
you have here is truly second to none
the problem is traditionally you have to
physically move to america to access all
these benefits
that's where first base dot io comes in
first base helps you incorporate your
u.s company from anywhere
so that you can access the greatest
startup ecosystem in the world no matter
where you're at
you fill out a simple application and
they take care of all the convoluted
paperwork from filing to opening up a
bank account for you
you'll also get over forty thousand
dollars in credits and discounts from
their partners like aws brex and more to
help you grow faster first base has
launched over 6
000 us companies for entrepreneurs and
160 countries in almost every u.s state
so whether you live in the us europe
africa asia the middle east
first base makes incorporating and
getting access to all the great tools
available to us companies as
easy as clicking get started and if
you're already in the us
incorporation makes a ton of sense to
make your business look more legit and
to build trust with clients
ride the wave and get a head start by
going to first base dot io and use code
jt to get a discount and white glove
concierge supports that's first based on
io with code jt with the link below
tim draper net worth 1.5 billion
category
early investor february 2011
the most notorious dark website launches
after six months of development
the silk road at its peak the silk road
allowed sellers of a list of goods to
sell to over a hundred thousand buyers
just four months later the website
gawker published an article about the
site
which brought a lot more public eyeballs
to the silk road leading to senator
chuck schumer calling for the fest to
shut down the websites
and within just around 3 years of
service the fbi shut down the website
and arrested the site's founder
ross albrecht who went by the name dread
pirates roberts
the fbi managed to track down the silk
road server despite the anonymity
software they use tor
this led to ross's attorneys claiming
that the fbi must have used illegal
searches in violation of the fourth
amendment to get their location
in reality the fbi said they found the
server's location simply by fiddling
around with the website's login page and
captcha elements you know
these annoying things because of a
misconfiguration of the captcha elements
it eventually leaked the server's true
location along with that shutdown came a
seizure of 26 000 bitcoins from users of
the silk road
worth 3.6 million at the time then came
another seizure of 144
000 bitcoins worth 28.5 million straight
from the founder himself
and that's where our future crypto
billionaire tim draper comes in
tim draper is a third generation venture
capitalist that's invested in hotmail
skype tesla spacex angelus solarcity
ring twitter docusign robinhood
ancestry.com twitch and many many more
june 2014 the u.s marshals auctioned off
almost 30 thousand bitcoin sees from the
silk road and 10 blocks in an online
auction
at that time that was worth around 17.2
million
july 1 2014 they announced that one
anonymous bidder won all 10 auctions
claiming all 30 000 bitcoins to
themselves one day later it was
announced that the winner of the auction
was none other than our venture
capitalist tim draper
the amount he paid for him remains
undisclosed draper had recently invested
in a crypto exchange for institutional
investors called verum and he said he
planned to use that bitcoin to provide
liquidity for the company
today that original 30 000 bitcoins are
valid at nearly 1 billion dollars
and forbes estimates his net worth at
1.5 billion
chiang ping cho net worth 1.9 billion
category infrastructure builder
chiang ping cho also known as cz is
pretty familiar with the restriction of
borders and overreaching governments
his father was targeted as a
pro-bourgeois intellect during the
cultural revolution in china and was
exiled to the countryside
and once his father was able to study in
canada cz had to wait five years to get
a visa to visit his dad and eventually
move there
today he runs binance the world's
biggest cryptocurrency exchange where
he's trying to get people to use the
form of money that doesn't have to rely
on borders and governments
taking the company from zero to the
number one exchange in the world in just
eight months
making him a billionaire in the process
as a teenager in canada cz had to work
to help pay the bills
flipping burgers at mcdonald's and
working night shifts at a gas station
at the age of 12 or 13 his dad bought a
286 dos computer
giving cc his first exposure to
computers which his dad always said was
the most expensive thing he had ever
bought
after he studied computer science in
montreal cz entered the world of stock
exchanges in both tokyo and new york
building a system for matching trade
orders on the tokyo stock exchange and
futures trading software for bloomberg
by age 27 he was moving up the ranks
fast but wasn't satisfied so a quick
move the shang had to start fusion
systems which made some of the fastest
high frequency trading systems for
brokers
watch this video to learn more about
high frequency trading
by 2013 his friends told him about
bitcoin at a poker game and how you
should convert 10 of your net worth into
bitcoin because there's a very small
chance it will go to zero and you will
lose that 10
and there's a high chance it will go 10x
and then you would double your net worth
so he got the bitcoin white paper and
being that he had a tech background and
has dealt with first hand the pains of
transferring money internationally
he went all in and then i sold my
apartment to buy bitcoin and also quite
my job
he joined blockchain.info first and
quickly realized that his strength was
still in the exchange trading business
2017 bitcoin has his infamous rally in
all the exchanges during that time kept
crashing they were clunky slow and worst
of all
none of them had customer supports he
already had a matching engine trading
system ready from his last projects
he saw that he can make the ui better
make things faster provide better
customer service reduce trading fees and
overall
provide a giant improvement over all the
competitors and boom
binance was born cz hyper grows it into
the biggest exchange in just eight
months
and today they're the biggest crypto
exchange in the world
they have 1600 to 1700 employees all
remote no headquarters very crypto-esque
they brought in 800 million in revenue
last year they're working on a ton of
initiatives and planning on acquiring 20
to 30 companies a year
and all the while cece lives a pretty
basic and minimal lifestyle
when asked by bloomberg what's the most
luxurious thing you've bought since
becoming a billionaire
cz answered i bought like five or six
laptops i actually destroyed laptops
pretty quickly they break
as soon as new ones come out i buy one i
don't have a car i don't have a house
the problem with cars houses is that i
just don't think they're liquid as soon
as you buy them you can't trade out of
them
easily you can rent an apartment or stay
in a hotel that gives you much higher
liquidity so i'm one of those guys who
value liquidity much more than owning
something
i actually prefer to own nothing today
force estimates his net worth at 1.9
billion dollars which cz says is 100 in
crypto
no fiat no investments i'm not using
crypto to buy fiat i'm not using crypto
to buy houses
i just want to keep crypto and i don't
plan to convert my crypto into cash in
the future
cz is a true believer
sam bakeman freed net worth 8.7 billion
the richest of the crypto billionaires
category infrastructure builder want to
trade socks 24 7 instead of just losing
money on weekdays
how about betting on how robin hood is
going to perform on his ipo or if donald
trump will win 2024
well you can do all that and more on ftx
one of the world's fastest growing
crypto exchanges that offers some of the
most riskiest most experimental crypto
derivatives
remember derivatives the things that
played a key role in the 2008 financial
crisis
while the derivatives market for things
like stocks is gigantic to say the least
with estimates putting out over one
quadrillion dollars
andre jake has a great video explaining
derivatives and how big one quadrillion
really is
which will be linked below and now you
can play with derivatives that are not
just option contracts for stocks or
future contracts for commodities like
wheat
those are boring and old school but the
rivet is based on crypto at the
underlying assets
like this bitcoin perpetual features
derivative or this leveraged three x
long bitcoin token
where bitcoin goes up one percent you go
up three percent but if bitcoin goes
down one percent you also go down three
percent
they also have a three x short bitcoin
token with the opposite is true
bitcoin goes down one percent you go up
three percent
and a ton of other very experimental
derivatives you can play with
except if you're in america because they
intentionally base themselves in hong
kong to specifically avoid us regulators
basically the exact opposite approach of
the winklevosses gemini
and their asked permission first not
forgiveness later approach and the
mastermind behind this offshore exchange
called ftx
a 29 year old billionaire named sam
bakeman freed who's a vegan
shares a hong kong apartment with
roommates often sleeps on the bean bag
and became the second biggest ceo to
donate to the joe biden campaign second
only to michael bloomberg
the son of two stanford professors sam
was contemplating going into academia
until he came across the effect of
altruism movements which says you should
do whatever it takes to maximize the
amount of impact you have
being a professor making an average
salary volunteering a few hours of your
time
versus going into finance making a
fortune and donating that fortune
sam chose the latter he started working
at a giant quantitative training firm
called jane street capital
and by 2017 once he got into crypto he
started a quantitative crypto trading
firm called alameda research
then in 2019 he founded fts because much
like cz with binance
he was frustrated with the quality of
the other exchanges at the time today
fts processes 10.7 billion trades a day
around four times more than coinbase
making them the fifth largest exchange
in the world
chris larson and jed mccaleb respective
net worth 3.4 billion and 2 billion
category coin mentors chris and jed are
the co-founders of ripple the company
behind the xrp token and what's called
ripple nets
as a co-founder chris holds more than 3
billion xrp tokens
and a 17 stake in ripple labs larson's
fortune grew by 800 million while xrp's
value skyrocketed
jed on the other hand holds around 3.4
billion xrp tokens this is where most of
his wealth comes from
after leaving ripple jet co founded
another crypto project in 2014 called
stellar lumens
of which he now owns 1 billion tokens
these numbers were taken in march 2021
so even with the recent giant crash of
xrp these two are still billionaires
today if you want to send money
internationally to your family back home
or for business
it's really bad it takes three to five
business days there are conversion fees
your money has to be routed through
multiple banks
and you still have to pay a wire fee so
ripple created their product ripple nets
with the goal of letting people transfer
money around the world as quickly as you
can send an email
while deducting almost no fees for the
service so instead of three to five
businesses it would be three to five
seconds using blockchain tech
and their altcoin xrp was created to be
used on the ripple net for these money
transfers
but unlike bitcoin where it has to be
mined when ripple created xrp
they minted all the coins into existence
right away a hundred billion to be exact
20 billion coins were split between the
founders and 80 billion went to ripple
labs
because of the way xrp tokens were
managed by ripple the sec classified xrp
as a security like a stock instead of a
currency
so the sec sues them the court case
between ripple and the sec is still
going on
but it looks like ripple may win my
friends over at slybean have a great
explanation of the lawsuit which i will
link below
today jed hosts his position as
co-founder and cto of stellar lumens and
chris larson continues as the executive
chairman of ripple labs
and these were just seven of the 12
known crypto billionaires out there
here are the remaining five michael
saylor net worth
2.3 billion michael sailor is the
current ceo of michael strategy
during his time with the software firm
he both made and lost millions during
the dot-com bubble
he made up for his losses by buying a
bitcoin for himself and his company
before the boom
and strategy just added another 489
million worth of bitcoin to its already
massive crypto holdings
matthew roshak net worth 1.5 billion
matthew got in early and bought bitcoin
way back in 2011.
today his early investment ranked him
1.5 billion matthew now acts as chairman
of the blockchain infrastructure firm
block which he co-founded he also
invests in a bunch of other crypto
startups
brian armstrong net worth 6.5 billion as
the co-founder of coinbase armstrong's
fortune grew by 600 during the last
crypto craze
coinbase is now one of the biggest
crypto exchanges out there with over 1
billion in revenue last year
the company recently decided to go
public fred earson
net worth 1.9 billion fred is the other
co-founder of coinbase
five years after founding coinbase he
left the company to eventually lead the
crypto investment group paradigm
even though he only remains as a board
member of coinbase his six percent stake
in the company is worth around 1.9
billion
barry silbert net worth 1.6 billion he
founded a crypto company called digital
currency group or dcg in 2015 which is
where most
of his fortune is dcg holdings include
coindesk a crypto news website and the
asset management company grayscale which
has over 44 billion in bitcoin ethereum
and other crypto assets under management
and even with the recent crypto crash i
have a feeling that this is just the
beginning of this new class
of billionaires
[Music]
guys i love researching videos like this
because you just get inspired especially
changpeng cho cz of binance i mean he
went from cultural revolution in china
to poor immigrant to a billionaire that
doesn't care to buy anything extravagant
that's pretty cool
and it makes me feel like a little bit
if you're looking to start your own
startup maybe in the crypto space you
should check out firstbase.io
first base has launched over 6 000 us
companies for entrepreneurs and 160
countries in almost every u.s state
and if you're already in the u.s
incorporation makes a ton of sense to
make your business look more legit and
to build trust with clients
you'll also get over 40 000 in credits
and discounts from their partners like
aws
brex and more to help you grow faster so
you can get your head started by going
to first base dot io and use code jt to
get a discount and white glove consumer
supports link below
let me know which story you found the
most intriguing about all the crypto
billionaires in the comments below
if you're new here we make video essays
just like this one every single week on
the most provocative stuff in the world
of business
for free so you should subscribe with
the red button below
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you